PROFESSOR ROBERT SHILLER:
OK, good morning.
So, I wanted to talk today about
Behavioral Finance or
about Psychology and Finance.
This is a longstanding
interest of mine.
I've been involved with
it for over 20 years.
It's not really emphasized in
your textbook, Fabozzi and his
co-authors talk about a lot of
things in the financial world,
but not about the underlying
human behavior.
Behavioral Finance, or
Behavioral Economics more
broadly, is a kind of revolution
that has occurred
in finance and economics over
the last 20 or 30 years.
And it remains somewhat
controversial.
I don't quite fully understand
why it is that people polarize
as much as they do, but some
people don't like this.
We're coming along to be
the majority, I think.
People are now regarding
Behavioral Finance as an
important element of finance.
But the real problem is that
people are complex and our
financial institutions, as I've
emphasized, are designed
for real people and their
functioning depends on the
behavior of real people.
And it's not as simple.
You know, another revolution
that's occurring parallel, of
bigger significance, is a
revolution in neuroscience
about the human brain.
And the human brain is a
very complicated organ.
Economists have liked to
invoke the principle of
rationality as an underlying
component of their theory, and
that has been useful, but it's
of limited use, because people
aren't rational.
They are often rational,
they're
not completely rational.
And very often, people
behave stupidly.
I'll put it that way.
That includes everyone,
including me, because we're
human and we have limits.
One thing about the human
species is that we are aware
of other people's weaknesses
and have an
impulse to exploit them.
So when you see other people
behaving stupidly, sometimes
you think, maybe I can turn
this to my advantage.
OK?
And that becomes a problem.
The history of humankind is a
history of exploitation of one
person by another.
Not entirely, but I'm saying
it has that as
an important element.
So, I'm going to talk about
these human failings.
It's not to say that people are
stupid, I'm just saying
they're people, and we're
all imperfect.
We're smart in some dimensions
and we can be very smart, but
we can also make important
mistakes.
But before I start, I wanted
to try to put this into a
perspective.
Maybe, I'll return to this at
the end of the lecture, but I
wanted to start out
on an upbeat note.
I'm going to talk about all
kinds of human errors, but I
wanted to start on an upbeat
note that the business world
generally doesn't exploit
people terribly.
I believe that very
characteristically successful
businesses in finance and
elsewhere consider their
long-term advantage and the
reputation they have. So,
doing something that is
blatantly exploitative of
human weaknesses will
work against
their long-term advantage.
You'll see a lot of human
failings, but we don't see
people cashing in on them
as often as you'd think.
And beyond that, I want to
emphasize also that another
aspect of human behavior
is morality.
Evolutionary biologists think
that this evolved along with
our other traits, that we have
an impulse to be moral.
And so, in the long run, you
might not really gain so much
satisfaction from exploiting
other people's mistakes.
And so, you don't necessarily
do that.
So, that's why we have a lot of
weaknesses outlined and we
won't see significant or serious
exploitation of them
as characteristic.
Now as you know, I have chapters
from my forthcoming
book assigned for this course.
And I looked back on what I put
up for you to read and I
keep thinking, gee, this
really wasn't ready.
So, I had a chapter for this
section of the reading list
about Behavioral Finance.
And I thought, I didn't
really get it right.
I know what I was trying to
say, but maybe I should --
what I start out in that chapter
is talking about Adam
Smith and his book The Theory
of Moral Sentiments.
Now just to remind you, Adam
Smith was a professor in
Scotland in 1759.
He was a professor of moral
philosophy, because there were
no professors of economics
in those days.
And he wrote in 1759 --
Maybe I should write some
of this on the board. --
He's probably the most important
figure in the
history of economic thought.
So, in 1759 he wrote his The
Theory of Moral Sentiments.
And in 1776, he wrote the
more famous book,
The Wealth of Nations.
So, this is The Theory
of Moral Sentiment.
The Wealth of Nations is
considered the first real
treatise on economics and
it's a wonderful book.
And it's still very
readable today.
His The Theory of Moral
Sentiments is
not so widely read.
But it's not really economics,
it's a book about psychology
and morality.
I find it very good, even
250 years later.
He went through many editions on
this book, because maybe he
thought it was his most
important work.
But the book starts out about
selfishness and altruism.
And the real question, which he
thinks defines economics,
is, are people really
completely selfish?
Sometimes it seems that way,
that their presumed
benevolence is just an artifice
for their own benefit.
But he wonders, how does an
economy work if everyone is
totally selfish?
And he ends up concluding
that they're not.
I thought it was very
interesting,
the way he put it.
The thing he emphasized right
at the beginning of the book
is that people inherently
love praise.
We crave the approval
of other people.
And so, praise is a fundamental
human desire.
But then he reflected on it and
he said, do people really
want praise itself or is it
something else that they want?
Well, think of it this way.
Suppose people made a big
mistake and thought that you
had accomplished something,
but there was a mix up.
You know, it was really
somebody else
who did it, not you.
And it's just a complete
mistake.
You had nothing to do with it,
but you find lots of people
praising you.
Would that really
be pleasurable?
And suppose you even know that
they'll never find out that I
didn't do it.
Well, Smith said, it
probably isn't.
Think about it.
You internally are thinking, I'm
getting all this praise,
but I know I don't deserve it.
So, I don't enjoy it.
And then he went on to say that,
especially among people
who are more mature, he says
more mature people --
not everyone makes this step.
But he says, adults, normal,
mature adults, make a
transition from a desire for
praise to a desire for
praise-worthiness.
I want to know that I am the
kind of person who will be
praised and I don't need
to get the praise.
And he said, it's that tendency
ultimately, which
makes an economy work,
that people don't
care just about praise.
He gives an example
of mathematicians.
And he said he's known many
mathematicians in his life and
he finds that they're
almost all obscure.
The public doesn't know
about mathematicians.
They couldn't explain to the
public what they do.
And they don't seem to care at
all, because they know the
public doesn't appreciate
mathematics.
And so, there's a few
mathematician friends who
understand what they do
and may praise them.
But ultimately, a mathematician
can sometimes do
the work completely unknown.
And it's the praise-worthiness
that drives these people.
You may think I'm being too
idealistic, when I say this,
but I think that the finance
profession --
this is what I was trying
to say in that chapter.
That the finance profession,
like other mature professions,
is really dominated --
although there's a lot of funny
things that happen.
It is really dominated by people
who have reached this
desire for praise-worthiness.
And so, you're not going to
exploit people extravagantly.
Just because, why
would I do that?
This is not a good thing.
I wouldn't feel good about it.
Well, some people will.
Now, I wanted to also mention,
not everyone reaches this
mature state that Adam
Smith describes.
And that's one of the
complexities of human society.
And I think that the finance
profession has a problem with
other kinds of people.
Now there's a whole branch of
psychology called Personality
Psychology that categorizes
people by their personality.
And we're not all the same.
And in our society, we have
many different kinds of
personalities.
A successful society promotes
people up who have the
praise-worthiness desire.
We try to recognize them and
we try to put people of
character into important
positions, with
not complete success.
But I wanted to just briefly
talk about --
this is a lecture
on psychology.
I wanted to talk about other
personality types.
And I was going to use a book
called The Diagnostic and
Statistical Manual Edition IV
published by the American
Psychiatric Association.
They're coming out with a
fifth edition in 2014.
DSM-IV is kind of a household
word around my house, because
my wife is a psychologist.
DSM-IV is actually
controversial among
psychiatrists, because it's
too cut and dry for
some of them.
What it tries to do is, identify
mental illnesses and
personality types in a
quantifiable, reproducible
way, so that we can define who
has this mental illness or who
has this personality type.
And so, it gives you checklists
and it says, the
patient must have exhibited at
least three of the following
five behaviors.
And then, there will be another
checklist. And so, you
keep score and you can actually
diagnosis personality disorders.
I'm just going to mention
one of the
many personality disorders.
One of them is called
APD, called
Antisocial Personality Disorder.
And so they have checklists,
but just to
give you a sense --
oh, and the Antisocial
Personality Disorder is called
psychopathy, or one kind
of APD is psychopathy.
Another one is called
sociopathy and --
I don't know.
There's a huge literature
on these.
But according to DSM-IV, 3% of
the male population in the
world is APD, and 1% of
the female population.
A simple definition
for APD is a jerk.
There are more male jerks than
female jerks, apparently,
according to their --
this is all quantifiable
and done.
But what is an Antisocial
Personality Disorder?
It has the following
characteristics: lack of
remorse, frequent lying, lack of
empathy, superficial charm,
shallow emotions, distorted
sense of self, constant search
for new sensations.
Have you met someone
like that?
You probably have, because
that's 3% of the population.
I'm not anti-male, when I point
out there are three
times as many jerks among
males as females.
Females have characteristically
different
personality disorders.
And you can look down the list.
It's much more than 3%
of the population that
would be diagnosed
with one or the other.
So, you know, an APD person
is manipulative, feigns
affectionate or warm feelings,
but doesn't feel them, and is
trying to deceive you.
Once a student came to my office
and asked to sign up as
my research assistant.
I was talking and I thought,
well, maybe.
I said come back
and talk to me.
Later on, I read about him
in the Yale Daily News.
He was an impostor student.
He was not a Yale student.
And he had been around to other
university campuses.
He was an impostor at like
three different campuses.
There was something wrong
with this person.
Kind of made me feel -- then he
came later and asked me for
a recommendation letter.
I couldn't believe it after I
read about him in the Yale
Daily News.
This is extreme.
And so, incidentally, someone
did a study of APD by going to
a prison and categorizing
the inmates
using DSM-IV standards.
And they found that 40% of
the prisoners had APD.
Also, neuroscience people have
found that there are
differences in the prefrontal
cortex that are
correlated with APD.
So it seems to be --
it's a problem we have in our
society that some people have
a brain structure that's
a little different.
And it may make it difficult
for them to
behave in a good way.
We're learning more and more
about neuroscience.
It's interesting to me that Adam
Smith's book still rings
true though after --
There's some basic common
sense that we all learn.
You have to judge people
and you have
to learn their character.
And you have to be a person of
character for, in the long
run, that's what you want.
It gives you what you
want in life.
Oh, another thing I wanted
to say is that people are
manipulable.
Unfortunately, true.
And unfortunately, we live in
a world where it's hard to
avoid manipulating people at
all, because we have a free
enterprise system that
encourages competition.
And if the competition is
manipulating people, how do
you completely stay
clear of that?
I think, this is one of the
contradictions of our society.
A very simple and obvious
manipulation is, they'll put a
price on some item they're
selling, like $9.99.
So you're like, well, why didn't
they just say $10.00?
Well, you know why
they didn't.
It's called ''pricing points''
in marketing.
Because $9.99 sounds
a lot less,
psychologically, than $10.00.
So, everyone does it, almost
everyone does it.
But is that bad?
Well, it's bad in a way.
It's manipulative, isn't it?
I mean I'm annoyed by it.
Maybe you are, too.
But if you were in business,
would you do that too?
You might feel that you have to
and it's a harmless sort of
manipulation.
It's not hurting
anyone really.
They're maybe buying a little
bit more than they want.
See, that's the kind of
thing that comes in.
So, in looking at financial
institutions, they're often
manipulative in that sense.
It's similar to a politician.
If you want to be a member of
Congress or whatever, you
can't say what you
really believe.
Because you won't get elected.
You've got to kind of
doctor your opinions
to the public opinion.
But you might have a moral
purpose underlying it all,
because you want to
get elected so
you can do good things.
So, you do end up
saying things.
So, it's hard to judge
people, good or bad.
It's an overall sense you get
of someone's character.
That people are doing things
that appear somewhat
manipulative and somewhat bad,
but you get an overall sense
of the person through time.
And ultimately, our society,
within limits, rewards people
that show character through
all the confusing details.
Now I wanted to move -- that
was my introduction.
I wanted to move now to
discussing some particular
aspects of Behavioral
Finance, or more
broadly Behavioral Economics.
And about human failings that
are exploitable by somebody
and are somewhat exploited,
but remain.
I wanted to start out with
what's probably the most
famous element of Behavioral
Economics.
It's Prospect Theory and
it was invented by two
psychologists, Daniel Kahneman
and Amos Tversky, in the late
20th century.
They called it Prospect Theory
because it was a theory of how
people form decisions
about prospects.
And a prospect is a gamble.
It's about people's decisions
under uncertainty.
And in very simple terms, the
Prospect Theory says --
now there's a huge literature on
this, so I'm trying to give
you a very quick description
of it.
That there's something called
a value function, which
represents how people
value things.
And there's a weighting
function, which shows how
people infer or how they deal
with probabilities.
And I just wrote simply what
Kahneman and Tversky say.
I'll draw a picture of the
value function and the
weighting function.
And this will be very quick and
you'd have to read more,
but the way people value
gains or losses --
let me see.
I better draw the line
in the middle.
OK, and we're talking about
financial gains, so these are
gains, and this is zero,
and this is losses.
Well, negative.
What I have on the horizontal
axis is wealth or money or
something like that.
Zero in the middle.
And then, we have on this
axis value, which is
something like utility.
I'll erase my zero, so it
doesn't get in the way.
What they find is,
that people's
value has a funny shape.
We don't weigh gains and
losses linearly.
In the positive quadrant, when
we have positive gains,
there's diminishing
value like that.
It doesn't ever slope down.
It's concave down like
diminishing marginal utility
in economic theory.
But for losses, it looks
something like this.
It's concave up.
I'm exaggerating a little bit,
but this is a diagram that
Kahneman and Tversky wrote in
their famous Econometrica
article 30 years ago.
So, there's diminishing marginal
utility for gains,
but there's the opposite --
well, we have concave up.
And there's a kink.
Note that the value function
has a kink at the origin.
So, what does this mean?
OK, first of all, this
origin is a --
from what point do I estimate
gains and losses?
That's called the reference
point and it's psychological.
And it's subject to
manipulation.
The reference point
is the zero, from
which I measure things.
So, first of all, the reference
point is probably
today's wealth.
But it can be something else if
people are manipulated by
the way something is
presented to them.
Framing, according to Kahneman
and Tversky, is presentation.
So, I can give the same prospect
to people, but word
it in different ways
that suggests a
different reference point.
And that will change
people's behavior.
So, you can manipulate people
by describing something in
different terms, by suggesting
a different reference point.
But typically, the reference
point is today's wealth.
The kink means that people are
very conscious of little
changes in their wealth and
they're spooked by them.
I'm really afraid, because my
value drops very rapidly, even
for a small loss.
So, if you were to say,
lose $5 this morning.
You had it in your pocket and
you lost it on the way to this
lecture, you would feel
exaggeratedly bad about that.
You should really regard $5 as
just nothing, because the
present value of your lifetime
income is in the
millions, so what's $5?
But you don't think that way.
So, you're spooked and deterred
by small losses, and
less encouraged by
small gains.
So, this kind of thing allows
businesspeople to exploit
people if they want to.
If people are so focused on
these little changes, then you
are encouraged in business to
try to pick things out the
people are paying attention
to, like small things, and
sell insurance policies
on just those things.
Insurance should be concentrated
on the really big
things, like life insurance.
You know the fact that one of
your parents could die and the
children's family would be
out of money for the
rest of their lives.
That's a big thing.
But it may not work to sell
that kind of insurance.
You can do something that is
more focused on what people
are watching and make it
something little so that it
doesn't require them to
spend so much money.
The classic example of that
is funeral insurance.
You go around telling people
-- and for some reason this
sales pitch works, and it's
worked for thousands of years.
They sold this in
Ancient Rome.
You tell people, if someone in
your family dies, you can have
an expense of getting a proper
burial for this person.
It costs money.
And so, they would insure
that one thing.
And it was a little thing, but
it works to sell that.
Another example of it is airline
flight insurance.
You're insured for this flight
on the airplane.
I heard an ad for funeral
insurance recently.
They're still doing this after
2,000 years, because it still
works and it's manipulative.
That's not what you should
do for people.
You should not pick out
some little thing.
Or they also have diamond
ring insurance.
After an engagement, some women
will want to buy an
insurance policy on the diamond,
because it can
actually fall out of your
ring and you lose it.
But that's like, what is it?
$5,000 or something?
It's not big, it's
not essential.
And if you're insuring that and
not other things, you're
making a mistake.
Fortunately, the insurance
industry is not too --
it has come around to do
things that are more --
they are doing things that
matter and are big.
And that's because this Kahneman
and Tversky value
function is --
it represents an error that
people are prone to be making.
But it's not total
and not complete.
And so ultimately, people
don't go to insurance
companies that manipulate
them.
It gets around and eventually
people come around in wanting
something better.
So, while there is some
manipulation, it's limited.
The other aspect of Kahneman
and Tversky is
the weighting function.
I'm going to draw again
a picture of it.
This time it's how people
psychologically think about
probabilities.
This again is Kahneman
and Tversky.
A probability is a number
between 0 and 1 or 0 and 100%.
I'll put 0 here and 1 here.
We can tell someone the
probability of something, but
they can't accept it
psychologically.
The errors that people
make are described by
the weighting function.
What the waiting function is,
it's the psychological impact.
You are behaving as if you
just don't understand the
probability.
So, what Kahneman and Tversky
say is, that for very low
probabilities people may
round them to zero.
And for very high probabilities,
they may round
them to one.
But if they decide not to round
them to zero or one,
they exaggerate the difference
between zero and one.
You just can't think in terms of
a continuum of probability.
So, this is what the weighting
function --
this is the weight as a function
of the probability.
For low probabilities
it's zero.
I'm going to maybe exaggerate
it here.
Then it jumps up.
It's something like this, and
as it gets close to one, it
jumps up to one again.
So you see, it's like a
broken line segment.
And there's been various
versions of this theory, but
this is the simplest
version of it.
So that means, if you're getting
on an airplane, you
think, well, what's
the probability of
this airplane crashing?
Well it's probably something
like 1 in 10
million or, what is it?
Even less than that.
So most of us, in our
mind, just say, it's
zero and I'm done.
I'm not going to think about.
I'm not going to
worry about it.
So, we're down here.
We've rounded it to zero.
But some people don't
round it to zero.
And for them, they just blow
it out of all proportion in
their minds, and it becomes
exaggerated.
So, I have it here, so it
looks like it's a half.
This would be one here and
this is about 0.4.
And then ultimately, if the
probability gets really high,
then I'm not even going to
think about it, it's one.
In some of the most primitive
languages in the world,
there's only a couple
of numbers.
There's zero.
There's one.
Maybe there's two or
three, and then
there's no more numbers.
Well, our minds are still very
primitive in dealing with
probability.
So it's like there's only
three probabilities.
Can't happen, may be,
and will happen.
So, I think airline flight
insurance is an example of
trying to manipulate this
personality characteristic.
So, it means that they'll
catch all the people who
exaggerate it.
They used to have vending
machines outside of airlines.
The vending machines would
encourage you to buy just for
this flight.
They put it right there when
you're getting on the flight.
And so that's when you're
most nervous.
If you're one of these
people who's up here.
And of course, most people don't
buy it, but they don't
have to sell it to everybody.
They just sell it to these
people and they charge an
outrageous price.
But I haven't seen these vending
machines anymore.
This is interesting.
Economists wrote about them 30
or 40 years ago and they used
to be everywhere.
And they just kind
of disappeared --
Do you ever see one of these?
I think they're gone.
Why is that?
Well, somehow we get past
things like that.
It's not like Kahneman and
Tversky are representing
immutable errors.
These are errors that
naturally happen.
But you can get past it.
And you end up wanting to deal
with people you trust. So, you
see some vending machine at
the airport and you think,
well, my insurance agent isn't
recommending I get this.
I've got some kind
of insurance.
So, you walk past it.
There's a professor in Germany
at the Max Planck Institute in
Berlin, Gerd Gigerenzer, who
has been taking on Kahneman
and Tversky in saying that
they're right that people show
these tendencies for errors.
But I can train people out
of them with no problem.
I just tell them this is an
error, and teach them then,
and they don't do it anymore.
Gary Gorton just did a seminar
here on errors that people
make in financial --
No, Nick Barberis here at SOM,
and he was using Caltech
students and found that --
and tested their ability
to prevent certain kind
of errors like this.
And he found that even the
Caltech students made these
errors just horribly.
We're wondering, aren't they
supposed to be bright?
Those are young math geniuses.
But about a third of them
got everything right.
So I'm thinking, you know,
they're only undergraduates.
By the time they get along, if
they go -- they'll eventually
be trained out of
these errors.
But right now, they're behaving
just like Behavioral
Finance says they will.
So anyway, I think that you will
find that Prospect Theory
explains a lot of things that
go on in finance, but it
doesn't explain everything.
And let me move on.
So, we want to talk about --
let me see.
I have got so many things
to tell you about here.
And I'm thinking
about my time.
It's a huge field, Behavioral
Finance.
Let me mention a few
other things.
Regret Theory is a
theory that --
it's kind of related to
Kahneman and Tversky.
It says that people fear
the pain of regret.
There's an old expression.
"I was kicking myself,"
because I
made some bad decision.
Well, that's a painful
experience when you did
something wrong.
This is represented somewhat
in the kink in the Prospect
Theory value function.
But Regret Theory says that
there's actually a painful
emotion, that you're
wired not to like
to have made a mistake.
And so then, you end up
designing your life around
that and trying to avoid
doing anything that you
might regret later.
And it can create problems. You
may make bad decisions,
because you're overly worried
about regret.
Gambling behavior.
Anthropologists have reported
that gambling occurs in every
human society.
And so, it's one of the
human universals.
Not that everyone does it, but
in every society you'll find
people that do it.
I have a 1974 study.
It found that 61% of U.S. adults
actually gambled at
least once for money
in that year.
I bet, it has gone up.
There's more opportunities for
gambling and it's gone up.
1.1% of men are compulsive
gamblers and 0.5% of women.
This is another male trait.
Somehow men are more vulnerable
to compulsive
gambling than women.
But it's only a factor
of 2-to-1.
But it's an addiction
that happens that
distorts people's thinking.
And it's such an addiction that
we have an organization
called Gamblers Anonymous that
helps people with this.
It ruins people's lives.
People end up getting a divorce,
because you can't
stay with someone, married to
someone, who is squandering
the family money.
They do it.
They end up sneaking around to
gamble, like drinkers sneak
around for the next drink.
Gambling behavior, it seems to
be associated psychologically
with a self-image, a sense of
who I am and why I'm an
important and good person.
A sense of competence.
Most gamblers do things that
they think are revealing of
their competence.
And they tend to pick a certain
form of gambling that
they become psychologically
identified with.
And they avoid any other
form of gambling.
Gambling behavior is part
of what goes on
in the stock market.
Certain people who have a
personality, which makes them
particularly interested in
gambling, find that a life in
finance can give them the
kind of stimulation.
Gambling behavior, by the way,
is almost like a drug
addiction in a sense.
People who are depressed may go
to a gambling casino as a
way of getting themselves
out of the depression.
And they say that when they walk
into the casino, suddenly
my troubles are gone.
I feel invigorated and alive.
It's almost like it creates a
hormonal difference that they
seek, and it's almost like
injecting yourself with
something, so it's a very
hard thing to conquer.
I mentioned before, when the New
York state in 1811 created
the first corporate law that
produced a lot of questionable
companies, people then said,
this is just gambling.
It's bad.
But the other side of it is
that this same gambling
behavior, it's not usually
a pathology.
It's an aspect of human
sensation-seeking of various
aspects of our psychology
that drive us.
What the stock market is, in
some sense, is a way of
channeling this kind of behavior
into something
productive instead
of just a game.
And so, they make it very clear
in the stock markets of
the world, this is about
business and this is
productive.
The same emotional patterns that
created gambling behavior
as a human universal
underlie some --
this is not abnormal,
it's most people.
Underlie traits that
work out well.
OK, the next major thing I
wanted to talk about is
overconfidence.
And psychologists have found
that there's a human tendency
to overestimate one's
own abilities.
We all think --
not all of us, most of us think
we're above average.
Some of us think, we're
way above average.
And this tendency has been
revealed in a number of
experiments.
I thought I would
try one on you.
I don't know if it will work.
I'll try it on this class, if
you will participate in this
experiment by a show of hands.
I'm going to ask you --
I have three questions here.
And I want to ask you
to write down a
90% confidence interval.
Do you have a pencil
to write this down?
And then afterwards, I'm going
to tell you the answer and see
if it fell in your confidence
interval.
OK, so this is what it is.
What is a 90% confidence
interval?
It's a range of values, so that
you are 90% sure that the
true value lies in this range.
So, if I asked you, what is the
population of New Haven?
You might say, 90% confidence
interval that's between 50,000
and 150,000.
That means, you're 90% sure that
the population falls in
that range.
And so, you should be right
90% of the time.
If I ask you to give 90%
confidence intervals, you
should be right 9
times out of 10.
If I ask for a 99% confidence
interval, you have to widen
the interval so that you
should be right 99
times out of 100.
So, what I'm going to ask you
to do, if you will cooperate
with me, is give 90% confidence
intervals for --
I have three questions I'm
going to give you.
But I have to ask you to be
honest, otherwise this thing
won't work.
You could game me by just
giving excessively wide
confidence intervals, right?
From the ''zero-to-infinity''
type.
Then you'll always
be right, but
you're not playing honestly.
So, I have to appeal to your
character to do this honestly.
So, I have three
questions here.
I just changed the questions.
The first is --
now what you have to write
down on your notepaper
somewhere is your honest
estimate of a
90% confidence interval.
And so, the first question is,
the world population --
how many people are alive
in the world?
As of, I think it
was 8:00 a.m.
this morning
[addition: February 21, 2011].
The U.S. Census has something
called the World Population
Clock and just go --
don't cheat.
I know, some of you
have laptops.
Don't do it.
But after this you can search
Google on World Population
Clock and it shows you
minute-by-minute how many
people there are in the world.
Every birth and death.
It's not actually recorded,
it's a fake.
But I mean it's supposed
to be an estimate.
So, I got the world
population.
So, what I want you to do, can
you write down a lower bound
and an upper bound for the world
population this morning
as measured by the
U.S. Census?
OK, can you write that down?
But I don't want you to
make it too wide.
Remember, I only want
you to be 90% sure.
And I don't want you to make
it too narrow, because then
you're more likely to fail.
So, you've written that down,
the world population?
OK, my next question is --
2.
The world, what does it weigh?
Well, actually, it's the mass,
in kilograms, of the world.
Can you write that down?
This is astronomy.
Let me say, I'm asking for it
in kilograms. But you can do
it in metric tons.
That just knocks off
three zeros.
A metric ton is 1,000 kilograms.
And just so you'll
know for sure, that's not the
same thing as a long ton,
which is U.K. The United Kingdom
uses the long ton,
which is 2,240 pounds.
I just looked this up.
And is 1.1 metric ton.
And it's not exactly the same
as a short ton, which we use
in the United States, which is
2,000 pounds, which is 0.98
metric tons.
Just tell me, how many tons.
That's not going to
affect your 90%
confidence interval, right?
Just tell me how many tons
does the earth weigh.
And then that's the second and
I have one more question.
How many languages are
there in the world?
Now, I know you might complain,
this is a matter of
definition, because sometimes
two dialects might be
considered a separate
language.
Well, I'm asking you to
give me the number --
the World Authority on languages
is an organization
that has a website called
ethnologue.com.
And if you go to that website,
they're always
discovering new languages.
They keep track of it.
New languages keep getting
discovered, because some guy
is hiking out in Siberia and
they go to this little
village, and say, hey, these
people are speaking a language
that has never been
documented before.
So, it's this process of
learning languages.
They also keep dying out,
because there's just elderly
people in this village, and when
they die you know this
language is going to
die with them.
So anyway, the question is,
I want your 90% confidence
interval for the number of
languages, as defined by
ethnologue.com.
You have to guess how they
define a language.
But you have an idea more or
less what a language is.
It's more than a dialect,
because they can still
understand each other if they
speak different dialects.
We're talking about really
different languages.
OK, have you written down three
confidence intervals?
OK, so I'm going to write
down the answers
and I hope this works.
I'm trusting to your honestly
in getting these things,
because you good game me
and make this not work.
But give me your honest count.
So, I'm going to write down
the correct answer.
So, the world population
as of 8:00 a.m.
this morning
[addition: February 21, 2011]
was 6,901,330,581.
Now, can I get a show of hands,
how many peoples'
confidence interval includes
that number?
OK, can someone tell me
what percent that is?
That is not 90%.
You're doing pretty
well, though.
What do you think, Oliver?
STUDENT: About 80.
PROFESSOR ROBERT SHILLER:
You think it's 80?
Let me see them up again.
Maybe it is 80, all right.
You're doing really well.
Some honest people here didn't
put their hands up.
All right, well, that's one.
So, we did 80 instead of 90.
What about the weight
of the earth?
In kilograms. Well, it's 5.974
times 10 to 24th power.
And I'll give you
that in tons.
It's 5,974 billion
billion tons.
You got that?
You might have to do
some calculation.
It'd be 5.9734 times 10
to the 18th power.
[correction: 5,974 times
10 to the 18th power is
the weight in tons.]
OK, can we do a show of hands?
How many people had
a number in --
how many people are in the
confidence interval there.
All right, Oliver, what
do you think?
What's the fraction?
STUDENT: 5%, maybe 10.
PROFESSOR ROBERT SHILLER: 10%.
OK.
So this one, we did really
well on world population.
80, 10.
The last one, how many languages
are in the world?
Well, according to
ethnologue.com there are 6,909
languages this morning
[addition: February 21, 2011].
How many people got that within
their confidence interval?
OK, what do you think, Oliver?
STUDENT: About the same, 10%.
PROFESSOR ROBERT SHILLER:
10%, OK.
Why did you do so much better
on world population?
Well, thank you for being
honest with me.
I think it worked once again.
The overconfidence.
So, why is it that people are
overconfident like this?
And psychologists have tried to
describe, what it is that
goes on in people's minds that
produces answers like this.
One of them is, that people seem
to have a sense that they
understand the world more
than they really do.
It's an illusion.
Actually, the world is just
infinitely complicated and
there are so many surprises.
When you think about a question
like this, there's
many different perspectives
that you can take.
And if you thought more about
it, your imagination might
help you to widen your
confidence interval.
But you can't think of all
the perspectives at once.
And so, you tend to gravitate to
the first one that comes to
mind and it gives you an
underestimate of the
confidence.
So, that is overconfidence.
By the way, I think it's a
little bit higher in males
than females.
I didn't do a separate
male/female count.
But females [correction: males]
are definitely overconfident.
That's the so-called macho
personality that's supremely
overconfident, which is --
that's not in DSM-IV. I don't
think it is, but it is more
common among males.
But it's really, everyone
is overconfident.
There's no important sex
difference here.
Incidentally, I think that
overconfidence, and this is an
important phenomenon, it
goes beyond yourself.
It extends to your friends.
And you exaggerate --
there's a tendency for people
to think that I have very
smart friends.
I was reflecting
the other day.
When I was an undergraduate at
University of Michigan, I was
in the honors program and we
thought we were pretty smart.
And I had a number of young
people that I just imagined
were heading toward really
great careers.
There was one student that we
called Young Jack Kennedy.
You know, this was
some years ago.
Jack Kennedy was president
of the United States.
We thought he was a genius.
That was probably wrong, too.
None of these people
are geniuses.
I was thinking that most of my
friends ended up in very good
careers, but nothing that you
would think was spectacular.
I had one friend as an
undergrad, who I thought was a
genius, and his name was
Bruce Wasserstein.
Anyone ever heard of him?
Maybe not.
Well see, that's it.
But he founded his own
investment bank called
Wasserstein Perella, became
really rich and then he bought
interest in Lazard Freres, the
French investment bank.
He was a real big shot
on Wall Street.
I met him again about 10 years
ago and then he died.
God.
He had a heart attack
and died.
So, I know his whole life.
I saw him when he was 18 and
I've watched his whole life,
and it's now history.
It's kind of scary.
But I remember thinking he was
a genius as an undergrad.
I was wondering, what was
wrong with my judgment?
Why did I see so many
other geniuses?
Now that I think back on it,
he had a sort of real world
common sense that amazed me.
He just knew things that --
it wasn't fake knowledge.
He seemed to know how
things worked.
So, I guess I was right
about one of them.
But not enough that none of you
have heard of him right?
He has an investment bank
named after him.
You should have heard of
him, but maybe not.
But anyway, this thing affects
peoples' thinking, too.
I think that we tend to think
that the head of state who is
running, the head of our central
bank is a genius.
And this really clouds
our thinking.
It's like our ego extends to
the other people that we
associate with ourselves.
Now, the head of a central bank
in another country we
have no respect for.
It's only in our own country,
because it's part of our ego
involvement that produces
this overconfidence.
This tendency for overconfidence
produces a lot
of anomalies and opportunities
for manipulation.
So, for example, Rakesh Khurana,
who is a professor at
the Harvard Business School,
has written a book called
Search for the Charismatic
CEO.
He claims that there's a
tendency for people to think
that CEOs are geniuses.
Or at least the one that
we found is a genius.
And companies then seek out a
genius CEO to put in charge of
the company as a kind
of manipulation
of the stock market.
They think if we get -- you
know, if we got some guy who's
run other companies successfully
in the past, he
must be a genius.
Put him in our company, our
stock price will go up, then
we can sell our executive --
we can exercise our options
and make a lot of money by
putting in this fake genius.
And Khurana says, well, there
are some people who are maybe
geniuses at management,
but most of the time
they're just lucky.
And we tend to develop
overconfidence.
And then what happens, according
to Khurana, is, you
put in some guy who turned
around some company
spectacularly, supposedly.
You bring him in to run a new
company and he doesn't know
anything about this
new company.
But he has to justify himself,
so he lays off a lot of people
and shuffles things around, and
just destroys everything
in the company, and
ruins things.
This is related to another
author that I recommend.
I've mentioned him
before, I think.
Nassim Taleb wrote a book called
Fooled by Randomness.
He's Lebanese, but now in the
U.S. Nassim Taleb, Fooled by
Randomness, that says that most
of the things that happen
in life are just chance.
We tend to ascribe them.
If they happen to us,
we conclude --
we're very quick to conclude
that it's a
sign of our own genius.
And if it happens to someone
that is a friend of us, then
you think, well, I have genius
friends, isn't that nice?
And so, it leads to mistakes.
OK, let me go to another --
how much time do I have --
cognitive dissonance.
This is another psychological
principle.
The term was coined by
sociologist Leon Festinger in
the 1950s, I believe.
I actually met this guy.
That's the nice thing about
being in academia, you meet
all these great names if
you're in long enough,
eventually.
But what is cognitive
dissonance?
It's a judgmental bias that
people tend to make, because
they don't want to admit
they're wrong.
Maybe I'm oversimplifying
this mistake.
It's painful to think, that I
believe something and it was
wrong, so people will cling to
old beliefs and try to find
evidence that supports their
beliefs, because they have an
ego involvement with
the belief.
And so, I will be biased.
The famous experiment
indicating cognitive
dissonance, done by some
psychologist, had the
following form.
They got a list of people who
had just bought a car and they
knew what make of car.
They got the list from car
dealers, so they knew exactly
what car they had just bought.
And they called these people
up and asked them to
participate in a psych
experiment.
Or I think they said a
marketing experiment.
They didn't let them know that
they knew what car they had
just bought.
And then, the experiment
was the following.
Let's go through a number of --
what magazines do you read?
And they said, let's
get these out.
They got all the magazines that
were on the newsstand.
And they said, let's look
through page by page and tell
us which ads you remember
reading.
What they found is, that people
read the ads for the
car they just bought.
And they avoided especially the
car that they thought they
might buy, but decided
not to buy.
So, after you buy a car,
you want to confirm
your belief in it.
So, you selectively get
information that
confirms your belief.
And so, this cognitive
dissonance is another factor.
It's been demonstrated.
It's an error that
people make.
It doesn't mean that people --
again, none of these
errors is unviable.
People will make the error and
then they'll learn from their
mistakes and they'll correct.
They're not totally cognitive
dissonant, but it's just a
kind of error that
keeps coming up.
So, I give you a couple of
examples of cognitive
dissonance and its effects
on finance.
So, Will Goetzmann, who is a
professor here at the Yale
School of Management, and a
couple of his co-authors found
that mutual fund investors --
when a mutual fund does very
badly in its investment
performance, many or most
investors sell the stock and
get out of it.
But some of them hang on.
And they thought that that was
due, perhaps, to cognitive
dissonance.
Because I bought this fund,
I don't want to sell
because I was right.
So, what they did is, they
interviewed these people and
they found that these people
didn't even know how badly the
fund has done.
They had blocked it out and
they had an exaggerated
impression.
An exaggerated impression of
this, which is characteristic
of cognitive dissonance.
You just forget the evidence
that's contrary to your theory
and you keep assembling
evidence that
supports your theory.
I have another example of
cognitive dissonance and this
one was produced by Professor
Sendhil Mullainathan at the
Harvard Economics Department.
And Mullainathan looked at
financial advisors --
and his co-authors.
What they did in this study --
that's a whole big profession.
I remember at the beginning I
pointed out how many hundreds
of thousands of financial
advisors there are.
What they did, it's an
interesting experiment.
They hired actors to go to
financial advisors and ask for
their help.
And the experiment was
the following.
They would say the same thing to
each financial advisor, but
the different actors would
present their existing
portfolio differently.
In other words, you'd go to the
advisor and you'd say, I
have a portfolio of investments
and I'm almost
entirely in money
market funds.
That's all.
You'd just say that.
You wouldn't express
any opinion at all.
Another actor would go and
say, I've got all of my
portfolio in tech stocks.
Or I've got all of my portfolio
in options.
Now, what should advisors
tell people?
Well, if they were acting really
professionally, they
should question the assumptions
that made the
actor supposedly put all their
money in one kind of
investment.
And many of the financial
advisors did, but
usually they didn't.
They didn't question
the actor.
They assumed that the actor, who
had put, supposedly, all
of the investments in money
market funds, was someone who
was very risk averse, or thought
that was the right
thing to do.
And they didn't want to
challenge them, so they would
walk out of there with maybe
a slightly different mix of
money market funds.
And somebody else who was in a
very risky portfolio, they
didn't challenge them.
And they even sent actors in
with almost all of their
portfolio in their own
company's stock.
Now if you work for Ford
Motor Company --
I noticed my uncle --
I had conversations with
him about this --
who worked for Ford Motor
Company and put all of his
life savings in Ford
Motor Company.
I said, Uncle Ralph, you
shouldn't do that.
Because it's your job and all
of your life savings.
What if something happened
to Ford Motor Company?
Fortunately, he didn't
work for GM, which
became worthless recently.
But it can happen.
You know, Ford could be
completely wiped out.
That's your life savings.
And you know what
he said to me?
He said, you know, I've worked
at Ford all my life.
They treat me well, I
believe in them, I'm
not going to sell.
So, there's lots of
people like that.
So, when they show up at a
financial advisor, the first
thing that they should do, the
financial advisor should tell
them, get out of your
Ford stock.
That's just too risky.
But only 40% of the financial
advisors did that.
The 60% left them mostly in
their own company stock.
Why did they do that?
Well, Mullainathan thought, it's
because the advisors know
there's cognitive dissonance,
and they're afraid to drive
away a new client.
Maybe they'll gradually do it
over a while, but you just
don't challenge their
deep beliefs,
whatever they say is true.
And so, they're kind
of yes-men.
Not all of them, and maybe
they'll come around.
It relates then, again,
to a moral dilemma.
If you are a financial advisor
working in private practice,
what do you do with people who
come to you, if you know from
experience that challenging
their deep-seated beliefs will
drive them away?
So, in the real world,
this is again --
I'm not sure that these
financial advisors are doing
the wrong thing.
If they would eventually tilt
them toward a more responsible
portfolio, they can't
drive them away.
I have a lot of -- so many.
Let me list some of the
others and move on.
What else should I talk about?
Anchoring.
Anchoring refers to a tendency
to anchor your opinions on
something that captures
your attention.
The famous anchoring experiment
by, it was again,
Kahneman and Tversky --
I could almost do this
experiment here in class with
you if I had a wheel
of fortune.
A wheel of fortune is
like on a game show.
You spin the wheel and it comes
up with a number between
zero and a hundred in this
particular wheel of fortune.
So, this is the experiment.
They asked their subjects,
how many people --
it had to be something
that had an answer
from zero to a hundred.
One of their questions was, how
many nations in the world
[addition: in percent]
belong to the United Nations?
So, they asked the question.
They said, don't answer
me just yet.
Think about that question.
What percent of nations
in the world belong
to the United Nations.
Then, they spun the wheel, and
it came up and it showed a
random number.
And then, they asked people
for the answer.
Well, it turns out that people
tended to give an answer close
to the number that just
came up on the wheel.
This is totally irrational,
right?
That wheel has nothing to
do with the answer.
And yet people were
influenced by it.
So then, they would follow-up
and ask them, hey, that number
you gave is the same as the one
that just came up on the
wheel, or it's close to it.
Why did you do that?
The guy would say,
just coincidence.
I wasn't influenced
by the wheel.
Of course not.
But you know they were, because
statistically they
proved that they were.
So, anchoring means that people
are attracted to --
they're affected by subconscious
things.
I shouldn't say subconscious.
They didn't make a logical
connection.
When you face real ambiguity and
you don't know the answer
and you've got to come up with
a decision, you are swayed by
the most silly and
random things.
There's a representativeness
heuristic.
This is also Kahneman
and Tversky.
And that is, that people
overemphasize certain patterns
that they think are
representative of what they've
seen before.
So for example, certain patterns
in the stock market
that may be very rare
and unusual.
If they remember it, if it
somehow attracted their
attention, they begin
to look for that
pattern again and again.
And they see it too often.
So for example, Head
and Shoulders, we
talked about that.
McGee, the technical analyst, he
saw the Head and Shoulders
pattern in the stock market.
And he saw that it crashed
after that.
But actually, it's pretty
hard to find those,
they're kind of rare.
And it's not the right way to
process data, to be looking
for patterns that are
representative.
And it invites manipulation.
So, I'll give you some
other bad behavior.
If people believe in the Head
and Shoulders, if they believe
that the Head and Shoulders
pattern of stock price
movements predicts a decline,
here's what I can do.
I'll take some thinly
traded stock.
I'll get a friend.
We'll trade back and forth and
we'll influence the price to
create -- we'll deliberately
create a Head
and Shoulders pattern.
And then we'll short the stock
massively, right at the time
when the head and shoulders
pattern
would give a sell signal.
We can make tons of
money doing that.
So, why don't we do that?
Well, we don't because
it's a manipulation.
[SIDE CONVERSATION]
PROFESSOR ROBERT SHILLER: I
want to then just conclude
with social contagion, because
it's so important.
This is my last --
and this is really social
psychology.
I'm running out of room here.
That's social contagion.
Social psychology reflects on
the fact that people are
interdependent, and what I
think is affected by what
others think.
There's something called
herd behavior.
That's a popular term.
It refers to the tendency for
people to move with the herd,
not consciously.
They don't think that they're
moving with the herd.
I might bring up a little
sociology here
and I'll use a term.
Everything has been psychology,
but the great
sociologist, one of the founders
of the discipline of
sociology, was the French
scholar Emile Durkheim at the
late 19th, early 20th century.
And he used the word
''collective consciousness.''
And that is, that our opinions
about what's happening are
formed by a collective
understanding of
what's going on.
We have a tendency to think of
ourselves as rational and
common sense --
all of our views come
from common sense
processing of facts.
I have a sense of belief about
what goes on in the world, but
I underappreciate the extent to
which my views are a little
bit arbitrary and shared by
millions of other people.
You live in a certain point in
time in history, and there are
certain kinds of facts and ideas
and anecdotes that are
circulating.
There's another term, this is
a zeitgeist. That's German,
but it's now English.
That means "spirit
of the times."
So, what Durkheim and other
sociologists allowed us to
understand is, that the
zeitgeist is determined by a
collective memory, a collective
set of facts that
we operate on.
This herd behavior creates big
swings in the stock market and
other things.
So, it has a huge financial
impact.
But anyway, I've listed a number
of Behavioral Finance
principles that really come
from psychology, and I've
talked about some tests or
examples of their proof of
their importance in finance.
But what do we conclude
from this?
I think that my conclusion is,
that we are evolving toward
better and better financial
institutions.
There is a lot of manipulation
and exploitation, but we as a
society have outlawed
a lot of it.
For example, I mentioned doing
a stock market manipulation
trick to create a Head and
Shoulders pattern.
That is an offense.
It will get you in jail
for doing that.
And we prosecute that now.
So, you can't do that.
I'm going to talk more about
this in the next lecture about
regulation.
But it's also people's moral
judgments that the people who
evolve to become important in
finance are people who have an
internal compass, a desire for
praise-worthiness that
eliminates --
I'm going to give just two
examples of some recent
articles about this.
In the current issue of the
Harvard Business Review that,
I assume, is still
on newsstands --
This is Harvard Business
Review.
There's an article by Michael
Porter and co-author Mark
Kramer, Porter is a well-known
professor at Harvard, in which
he argues that we're coming to
realize more and more about a
principle called -- he calls it
''shared value.'' Or they
call it ''shared value.'' And
that is that the manager of a
company shouldn't be
underestimating the importance
of shared value creation with
society, with other people.
That is, we're all in this
together, and if we're mature,
we recognize, for example,
that I don't want to be
exploitative.
I don't want to make the local
people in my town upset with
our company.
I don't want our labor force
to become disenchanted.
Now, what he's saying it's not
really about morals exactly.
It's more about long-term
value.
But I guess morals somehow
creeps into the same judgment.
That mature businesspeople see
shared value and that there
was maybe not enough
emphasis on that.
Financial theory was leading
us too much toward thinking
that a manager should be
selfishly pursuing a narrow
focus, like maximizing
the short-run
value of their shares.
Anyway, the other example I
have, which is also recent,
not quite as recent as that, is
a book that came out last
year by Anna Bernasek,
who is actually a
journalist, not an academic.
But it's called Economics
of Integrity.
Is that the title exactly?
Yes.
Economics of Integrity.
And her point in that book is,
that a sense of personal
integrity has dominated what
people do in the business
world much more than we
thought recently.
There has been too much
disregard of the fact that
people do things because
they're right.
She gives an example in the book
-- and I'll close with
this concept.
She said, let's consider milk.
Now, you drink milk
regularly, I hope.
It's good for you.
But it could poison you.
People used to get sick from
drinking contaminated milk.
And you don't ever hear of
anyone getting sick.
So she said, why is that?
Well, we have government
regulation of milk production
and there are laws about
purity of milk.
But she looked into it
and found that --
actually, she didn't think it
was mostly the regulation.
She thought that you are safe
drinking milk because of the
integrity of our
people, mostly.
That if you go out to some milk
company and talk to the
employees, they might not
generally even know about the
regulations.
But if you ask them,
they'll tell you --
I mean, are you careful to
keep this milk clean?
They'll tell you, well,
someone's going to drink this,
so obviously it's common sense
I'll keep it clean.
And what she says, it's not
primarily the regulation, it's
the integrity of the people that
makes the economic system
work as well as it is.
So, anyway, I've emphasized
both sides.
I've talked about human failings
and about people
exploiting these failings, about
people with antisocial
personalities.
But we have a system that
somehow eliminates this from
being the major factor
in our markets.